[Music]
welcome welcome welcome to Last Week
Tonight I'm thank you so much for
joining us it has been a busy week
elections on Tuesday saw big wins for
Democrats Ohio voted to enshrine
abortion rights in its state
constitution and the SAG strike finally
ended meaning that movies will be back
in production although to be honest I'm
not even sure that I need movies anymore
since this 17-minute video was released
of what I can only describe as a hamster
G be living its best
life it's a complete Masterpiece and it
goes on for 16 more minutes I mean
barbon Heimer was fine I liked it fine
but be honest it's just not as good as
that and I really hope you enjoyed
watching it I really do because we're
going to dive straight in with our main
story tonight which concerns the ongoing
war between Israel and Hamas a sentence
which is a terrible way to start a
comedy show and a great way to end a
first date and look before we even begin
I know a lot of the conversation
surrounding this has been extremely
heated you may have seen friends or
co-workers posting hot takes that have
shocked you suddenly that guy who
offered you Coke at a wedding is rising
thesis long Instagram stories on the
two-state solution Kathy from work is
posting something that's anti-Semitic in
a way that you really hope she doesn't
realize and it's all shoved in between
your favorite influencer showing whole
while also calling for a free Palestine
the internet is a wild place things are
understandably very tense right now and
it seems like everyone is finding
themselves making mistakes and I do mean
everyone meanwhile Kmart has had to pull
one of its Christmas items off the shelf
because of its unfortunate wording the
shopping giant selling ham Christmas
Calico bags with the slogan merry ham
Miss which appears to be too similar to
the name of the terrorist group Hamas
yeah that is too similar if you like
naming your child John Blain gasey it's
too close for comfort but spare a
thought for Australian Kmart there how
are they supposed to know that Hamas was
going to launch a terrorist attack so
close to the ham Mass season I think we
all definitely celebrate and have heard
of before it feels like ham mass starts
a little earlier every year doesn't it
one day it's hammeren the next your
neighbors hanging up Hamas lights and
celebrities have also found out the hard
way that it's easy to get things wrong a
few weeks ago Justin Bieber posted
praying for Israel over a picture of a
devastated City that he apparently
didn't realize was actually Gaza he then
deleted the post and reposted the same
prayers over a blank background which as
we now know thankfully did solve
everything there was also a statement
issued by a group of celebrities calling
for the immediate return of Israeli
hostages which TMZ covered like this
anyone involved it seems in the
Hollywood
industry uh all put their names to a
letter to President Biden it really does
feel like it's everyone it's Chris Rock
it's uh Gwyneth paltro it's uh can I ask
Adam Sandler it's let me ask you
something who doesn't want to get the
hostages up Bradley Cooper yeah you I
mean you're right you know what I mean
it's like it's a non statement of course
everybody wants the hostages up I just
think it's beyond ridiculous like if we
play that out for a second Joe Biden's
going to get this open letter and be
like what oh my God The Rock sign
this to get the hostage out like are you
kidding me yeah as much as I hate to
agree with paparazi sports center
they're right about that The Rock
probably isn't going to solve the
conflict in the Middle East it's one of
those things so obvious it shouldn't
need saying like pie tastes good or
Rainbows are pretty or Yoshi is amazing
in the sack look at that tongue end of
discussion but even as Harvey Levin
leveled some Fair critiques on the utter
futility of celebrity he couldn't help
taking a pretty strong stance of his own
the statement of a ceasefire is that you
are going toel to stop attack right so
you are going to then allow Hamas to
come back in and try to exterminate the
Jews in Israel and and isra presumably
their P their ceasefire means Hamas
should not be attacking either yeah yeah
wa wait wait that's that's exactly what
the ceasefire mean and Hamas is going to
Hamas attacked in the first place this
was a terrorist attack and the idea a
that there's going to be a ceasefire now
invites hamast just to do it again yeah
TMZ is now hashing out its preferred
solutions for what's happening in the
Middle East raising many questions
including what exactly is TMZ now it
used to be ESPN for be listers leaving
the airport and stories like this
celebrity died and not even their family
knows yet and now it's doing geopolitics
pick a lane guys it's either Josh Gad
spill's ice cream on his dog or Ariel
chiron's imp on US foreign policy you
can't have both the point is there are
strong opinions everywhere and in some
cases they've undeniably been informed
by bigotry anti-semitic and islamophobic
incidents including violent assaults
have spiked in the US in the past month
to put it mildly it's not been an easy
time to wear a yamaka or a hijab in
America over the last month and I say
that knowing it's not necessarily been
easy on our best days so there are a
thousand different reasons why this is
hard to talk about but it does feel
important to at least try
as you undoubtedly know on October 7th
Hamas Le militants launched an
unprecedented and brutal attack against
Israel killing over a thousand people
mostly civilians including women and
children in their homes and what has
ended up being the deadliest day for
Jews since the Holocaust over 200
hostages were taken including a
9-month-old baby most of whom have not
been returned it was hideous and it was
sickening in response Israel has
launched what's now become a month-long
Siege of Gaza cutting off nearly all
water food electricity and fuel to the
territory in just the first 6 days of
the war it dropped 6,000 bombs on a
strip of land just 25 mil long and at
most 7 miles wide that is nearly as many
as the record number that the US dropped
on Afghanistan in a single year as of
this taping more than 11,000 people had
been killed including at least 4,000
children there was almost no piece of
footage that I could show you from Gaza
that is not horrifying or heartbreaking
but we did find one piece of footage
where a child very aptly sums up what
things are like there how have the past
few days been
abdulaziz like
it's okay we can cut it out tell me
how have the past few days been
abdulaziz explain to us you mean about
the war yes how has it been with the war
like yeah of course it feels like
there is no other way to put it and
I'm honestly glad that he didn't even
try there I also appreciate him asking
for clarification when the reporter
started over sorry just to be clear
you're asking what it's like to live
through this war right okay I got it my
answer remains like next question
please I've got to say it is hard to see
a kid like that and then hear glib
pronouncement like this one from
representative Brian Mar of Florida I
would encourage the other side to not so
lightly throw around the idea of
innocent Palestinian civilians as is
frequently said uh I don't think we
would so lightly throw around the term
innocent Nazi civilian
during World War II there's not
this far stretch to say there are very
few innocent Palestinian civilians okay
that is not only disgusting it's also
evidently the sort of thing that you're
allowed to get away with saying on the
house floor with zero repercussions
because that's apparently where the
conversation is right now but just so
we're very clear there are absolutely
innocent Palestinian civilians in the
same way that they are eridians who
aren't brain dead bigots with a penis
for a head a Region's worst does not
represent them all and look we don't
have time to talk about the history of
the Middle East tonight and I know
you're thinking but John are you sure
about that aren't you school well fun
fact I'm not it just seems like that I'm
actually technically a comedy show I
just hide it better than most so I'm not
going to get into the thousands of years
of generational trauma in forming the
response to this including the Holocaust
and the NABA or Mass violent
displacement of Palestinians during and
after Israel's founding I'm also not
going to do a historical blowby blow of
how Palestinians came to live in Gaza
and the West Bank right now you can
Google that for yourselves or or even
Bing it that's honestly completely fine
too although I will say I wouldn't ask
Jeeves about this he has some
unexpectedly pretty nasty views on the
subject instead I'd like to zero in on
one of the biggest misconceptions that
you may have been hearing over the last
few weeks specifically the tendency to
collapse leaders and citizens when
discussing this to assume that Netanyahu
speaks for all Israelis or that Hamas
speaks for all Palestinians because that
is emphatically not the case so tonight
let's look at Hamas and Netanyahu how
they came to be in power whose interest
they do and don't represent and what
role they've played in bringing us to
this current conflict and let's start
with Hamas it's been around since 1987
as governed Gaza for the last 17 years
it was founded in part in opposition to
where Palestinian Poli ICS was heading
at the time with the dominant political
party F embracing a peace process with
Israel a process by the way the
Palestinians had high hopes for when it
started but Hamas branded itself as the
party of resistance to Israel and
undermined the peace process with a long
series of attacks and suicide bombings
and as prospects for peace collapsed
Hamas seems to be Vindicated in its
messaging and you can see that
philosophy continuing through to today
this senior Hamas official uh gazi
hammad recently doubled down on the
massacre of October 7th by saying we
must teach Israel a lesson and we will
do it twice and three times and for many
commentators all the citizens of Gaza
are implicated in that sort of rhetoric
thanks to one key fact that you hear all
the time the people of Gaza the
Palestinians elected Hamas people Hamas
Fighters Hamas terrorists to their Board
of Governors the people in Gaza elected
Hamas it's a terrorist organization that
is their government how do you say Hamas
doesn't represent the Palestinian people
when they voted Hamas in to represent
them okay so very quickly that is Tucker
Carlson's replacement at Fox Jesse wats
he's a lot like Tucker except less
charismatic way dumber and with somehow
even more of an I've killed someone
during a fraternity hazing accident Vibe
which is really saying something because
look it is true that garans did at one
point elect Hamas but if you think that
makes them all complicit in war crimes
their government commits then boy do I
have bad news for you about Decades of
US foreign policy and also there are
some huge asterisks on garen's electing
Hamas first that election happened in
2006 and there hasn't been one since and
given that children make up roughly half
of gaza's population that means most
gazans weren't even born when the last
election took place what's more Hamas
didn't win a majority it only won with a
bare plurality of the votes and it did
so by running against fatal which was
widely reviled for incompetence and
Corruption at the time those were the
key issues in that election also Hamas
went out of its way to present itself as
more moderate back then in fact here is
that same Hamas official who recently
Justified the October 7th attacks
shortly before that 2006 election we are
a moderate organization really we are
not radical organization and we are not
extremist or fundamentalist no we are an
open minded organization taking believe
in democracy and the freedom and
political
pluralization yeah Hamas really tried to
Rebrand itself kind of like dominoes did
when they ran ads admitting that the
sauce tastes like ketchup the crust
tastes like cardboard and they promise
to work days nights and weekends to get
better but unfortunately like dominoes
Hamas is a terrible organization that in
no way kept its
promises because in the Years following
that tone of open-minded Freedom clearly
fell away not only has there not been
another election most people in Gaza
don't believe they have the freedom to
speak openly one poll found that under
Hamas rule 68% believ that the right to
participate in a peaceful protest was
not protected or was protected only to a
limited extent and human rights groups
have said that Hamas forces have carried
out a brutal campaign of abductions
torture and unlawful killings against
Palestinians accused of collaborating
with Israel and have attacked members
and supporters of f their main political
rival and the truth is many G will say
that they don't want Hamas in charge
polls show if true peace were available
many Palestinians would embrace it in
fact one conducted right before October
7th found
73% favoring a peaceful settlement to
the Israeli Palestinian conflict and
it's notable that in July despite all
the restrictions on descent in Gaza
there were actually people on the
streets chanting slogans including
off Hamas and we want to live and look
even if all Palestinians in Gaza did
support Hamas which they do not the
Relentless bombings of civilians there
would still be ofh horen Collective
punishment is a war crime but the fact
is there is much more criticism of Hamas
in Gaza that Americans in general and
these in particular are willing
to admit Palestinians in Gaza are not a
monolith and nor importantly are
Israelis because now let's talk about
Benjamin Netanyahu a man who's been
prime minister of Israel for a combined
16 years here in the US discussion of
the current conflict sometimes conflates
the current Israeli government with
Israel as a whole as if the two are
entirely representative of each other
you'll hear we need to support BB and
Israel or this is not a time to
criticize Netanyahu but that is not the
case within Israel criticism of
Netanyahu there is fierce one poll found
that 76% of Israelis want him gone and
many blame him for the security lapses
that led to the October 7th attack and
immediately after that attack videos
went viral of Netanyahu ministers
visiting hospitals where some of the
victims were recuperating and being
yelled at just watch this one Minister
essentially get chased out of the
hospital first by a family member and
then by somebody who worked
there
[Applause]
for that is pretty intense I don't know
much about medicine but after seeing
that I'm going to assume that the
hypocracy
hospital kick them the out because
was clapping at her there like you do
when you're trying to get a bird out of
your house and while that anger at
Netanyahu has certainly intensified
since October 7th it's also been there
for a long time before the attack Israel
saw nearly 40 weeks of protest including
hundreds of thousands of Israelis
marching in the streets in opposition to
his plan that would effectively end the
independence of the Judiciary and
endanger civil rights and look Netanyahu
has always been a hardliner he's forced
his entire political Persona around an
extreme version of safety through
strength which has included active
opposition to the peace process at
crucial points when former Israeli Prime
Minister yitzak Rabin agreed to the Oslo
Peace Accord which attempted to set a
framework for an eventual resolution of
the Israeli Palestinian conflict
Netanyahu was fiercely against it
infamously speaking at a rally where
protesters chanted in Blood and fire we
will expel Rabin and Hof depictions of
him in a Nazi uniform soon after that
Rabin was killed by a far-right Israeli
extremist and rabin's Widow blamed
Netanyahu for stoking the Flames that
led to that and in the wake of that
assassination netanyahu's political
career seemed dead and it wasn't until a
series of bus bombings by Hamas in
Israel as part of their own efforts to
derail the Peace Accords that Netanyahu
was first elected prime minister and his
message of I am the only one who can
keep you safe has been consistent ever
since here he is in the runup to Israel
2014 election making that point
again I feel the Jewish nation is under
threat and I'm prepared to mitigate that
danger it's what the state of Israel
expects from me and it's what I'll
do well that is a big claim that just
hasn't dated very well honestly I
haven't seen a politician's words age so
poorly since Hillary Clinton tweeted
happy birthday to this future president
so he has always been hard right but
it's worth taking a minute to underscore
just how extreme his current government
is because the truth is Netanyahu has
been struggling to hold office in the
last half a decade voters there actually
endured five elections in just four
years because neither Netanyahu nor
anyone else could form a stable majority
he only made it back into Power last
year by forming a coalition with those
on the furthest rightwing of Israeli
politics leading to the most right-wing
government in the country's history his
cabinet is stocked with ex extremists
take itamar benav he's been convicted on
at least eight charges including
supporting a terrorist organization and
incitement to racism he was once
considered so Fringe the Israeli Army
rejected him from mandatory service but
he's now netanyahu's minister of
National Security meanwhile his current
Finance Minister betel smotrich has said
is there a Palestinian history or
culture there is none there is no such
thing as a Palestinian people he's also
advocated for victory through settlement
very basically seizing land in the West
Bank and driving Palestinians from their
homes to the point where quote I abort
their hopes of establishing a state
settlements are widely understood to be
against international law yet smotrich
wants a massive expansion of them and
Netanyahu gave him a special role in
charge of settlement Affairs but perhaps
the most surprising way that Netanyahu
has actually jeopardized Israel's safety
is that for years he deliberately used
Hamas as a way to under mind the
Palestinian Authority a rival to Hamas
which administers parts of the West Bank
and has much more legitimacy on the
world stage experts say that the idea
was basically divide and conquer if
Palestinian leadership remains split and
one of the main parties at the table has
a terrorism label on it it's going to be
much easier for Netanyahu to refuse to
engage with them and say that he has no
partner for peace here is smotrich
explaining that strategy out loud in
2015 the Palestinian Authority is a
burden and Hamas is a terrorist
organization that no one will recognize
and no one will give it status in the IC
no one will let them lead a decision in
the security Council the main pitch we
are playing now is international
delegitimization Hamas at this point in
my opinion will be an asset Hamas is an
asset if you are calling the group that
has repeatedly killed your people an
asset it shows pretty clearly that what
you care about isn't safety but total
control and for years netanyahu's
government was actually allowing
suitcases of cash to be delivered to
Hamas something by the way that earned
suitcases of cash the title most morally
disreputable way to transfer money for
the 900th year in a row when that
Scandal broke Netanyahu insisted that
that money was for humanitarian Aid
which still doesn't explain why it had
to be delivered in Luggage in the back
of a car the point is Netanyahu
took the risk of betting that he could
control Hamas and use them to his own
ends and he was horribly wrong about
that just to the point that his
ministers are now getting screamed out
of hospitals to so to recap so far
Palestinians and Israelis have both been
relentlessly let down by their leaders
and the result has been a decades long
cycle of extremism violence retaliation
and more extremism and Palestinians have
been on the receiving end of that
extremism twice over subject to the
inadequacies and and cruelties of a
Hamas government and the punishing
isolation and daily misery of an Israeli
one because Israel's approach to Gaza
has been truly punishing fencing people
in limiting exits and trapping them
inside of what has been called an open
air prison by many human rights
organizations life under a blockade
there has been hard for a long time even
when there aren't bombs flying the
United Nations says just 10% of gaza's 2
million people have access to Safe
Drinking
Water my children get sick because of
the water they suffer from vomiting
diarrhea all the streets are full of
aash or of garbage other people they
have no work they have not employment
when people here run out of electricity
they only get 3 hours a day they can
either use a small battery to try to
operate lights or they just go outside
and light fires this life has given EAD
like many GMS a sense of having little
to lose right and you can't really blame
him for feeling that way once you've
lost clean water sanitary space job
prospects and most electricity there's
really not much left to lose but hope
and it's worth noting that there is one
more major player in all of this that I
haven't mentioned yet and it's us and I
don't just mean the British who are
absolutely responsible for some of this
I'm talking about America because this
country has emphatically picked a side
in recent years we've given Israel $3.8
billion doar a year in military aid and
you can make geopolitical Arguments for
why that is or isn't a valid thing to do
but it means we're heavily implicated in
everything you've just seen just listen
to basam Adam mean a Palestinian whose
10-year-old daughter was killed by an
Israeli Border guard in 2007 my daughter
have been killed with America uper
unfortunately from an American M16
unfortunately from an American G
American Uniform and the soldier have
trained in America so everything is
American right everything is American
and I know that is hard to hear but the
fact is made in America is something
that we understandably love to brag
about when it's slapped on things that
we're proud of but unfortunately it's
not just tractors truck nuts and Toby
Keith songs sometimes it's stuff that's
killing people and so having explained
at least some of how we got here now
might be the time to talk about where we
are as of right now Hamas is still
holding all but four of the hostages
that it's taken and firing Rockets
toward Israel every day and Israel is
bombing relentlessly again thousands in
Gaza have been killed so far which
honestly shouldn't be a total shock
given the early on an IDF spokesperson
said out loud
the emphasis is on damage and not on
accuracy and there have been some
maddening efforts to downplay the
suffering in Gaza like when Israel's
ambassador to the UN said this last
weekend there is no humanitarian crisis
in Gaza in coordination with the US and
the UN we allowed the number of trucks
entering Gaza now with food and
medicines to reach almost 100 trucks uh
every day you've said this before that
there is no humanitarian crisis in Gaza
uh that's kind of an amazing statement
because there were humanitarian problems
there before the war and now obviously
it has gotten bad take take their
numbers
aside it has gotten to the crisis point
I'm I'm I'm not no I'm I'm not saying
that the life in Gaza is great oh okay
okay but I'm not saying it's great is a
ver understatement there that is
something you say when you're describing
the band at a wedding or a sandwich from
Panera Bread but it's not how you
describe life in the middle of a
war zone because those on the ground in
Gaza will tell you it's absolutely a
humanitarian crisis just watch this
woman who works with Doctors Without
Borders it is the the worst humanitarian
catastrophe I've experienced in my
lifetime you know there's an acronym in
the in the Gaza Strip right now you know
I'm a Pediatric Intensive Care doctor I
see a lot of suffering in my career
there's an acronym that is unique to the
Gaza Strip and it's called it's w
cnsf wounded child no surviving
family children and it is used not
infrequently in the last three weeks
wounded child no surviving family should
not exist as an acronym she's right and
personally I'm going to take my cues
about what constitutes a humanitarian
crisis from the humanitarians here and I
really don't have it in me to show you
footage of people in agony tonight but I
do want you to see some kids in Gaza
who've been displaced speak about what
they've been going
[Music]
through
for
foree
yeah I'd really like them to be able to
chill the out too cuz kids should
never be losing sleep due to the fear of
War they should only be losing sleep for
completely normal kid reasons like Tommy
aches from eating too much candy or
apparently for Australian kids staying
up excited all night because it's
Christmas Eve and you can't wait to see
if Santa brought you a Brand New Bag for
all of your holiday ham for some deeply
weird
reason it should be impossible to watch
those kids and not feel sh scattered
there is a natural human impulse to
protect children to grab a toddler you
don't know if you see them running into
traffic and if that impulse is broken or
decentivize by a government there is
absolutely a humanitarian crisis no
matter what any has to say about
it and look I don't have a solution for
peace in the Middle East and even if I
did which again I don't this really
would be the worst voice in which to
relay that message but it does seem to
me personally that a ceasefire has to be
the first step
that is something that people have been
calling for all over the world but it's
something that world leaders have been
reluctant to say just watch Justin
Trudeau almost say it and then correct
himself we need to see a cease uh we
need to see a a humanitarian pause so we
can flow uh we need to see ceasing of of
of the levels of violence that we're
seeing wow he stopped himself midw there
he literally ordered a ceasefire on the
word
ceasefire my only regret that he didn't
just keep that word salad or word
poutine going uh we need a ceasing of
the violence a stopping of the explosion
sort of a halting of the booms if you
will a halter boom would be great right
now and it's not just Trudeau Joe Biden
has said there is no possibility of a
ceasefire which is a hell of a thing to
hear from perhaps the only world leader
whose pressure could actually make one
possible and listen there are those like
noted mid east peace expert Harvey Levin
who will say and not wrongly that there
are real dangers to a ceasefire that
Hamas might regroup once the bombing
stops although that's arguably going to
be a danger whenever it stops so why not
stop right now continuing down this path
only creates more extremists which is
the last thing that anybody needs and I
don't want to say anything that denies
the pain of those in Israel who have
lost loved ones to a truly barbarous act
or who are waiting anxiously for the
return of hostages although you should
know some hostages families are also
utterly furious at the military tactics
that Netanyahu is employing right now we
have to engage in negotiations we have
to do it now they say that the only
solution is to destroy to flatten Gaza
they never mention the hostages never
right and you can see how infuriating
that would be and I know that for many
Israelis there is an understandable
sense of fear and precarity right now
amid the Spectre of Hamas attacks and
Rockets flying overhead but it's worth
also acknowledging the overwhelming
sense of precarity among Palestinians
living under a blockade and a barrage of
Israeli rockets and it has to be
possible to feel the pain in one
Community without denying it in another
it has to be that is perhaps the most
necessary precondition for peace because
real peace here will clearly be
difficult it it's going to be struggled
toward as part of a larger pursuit of
Justice which will in turn require an
honest and uncomfortable Reckoning with
all the decisions that brought us to
this point and I know that hope is
scarce right now but I did see something
this week which gave me a seed of hope
it involved this Israeli man Ramy
elhanan who lost his 14-year-old
daughter to Hamas suicide bombing 26
years ago he actually co-directs a group
called the parent circle with that
Palestinian man that I showed you
earlier where parents who've lost
children to this conflict get together
to work toward peace alanam was asked if
recent events had changed his worldview
at all and his response is worth
listening to you know we are in a circle
of blood for for the last 75 years and
this is just another round nobody
expected the viciousness and the cruelty
of this round but it was expected you
cannot put two million people in a box
close the cover and uh expect nothing
will happen it will not stop unless we
talk you cannot annihilate Hamas you
cannot ignore six million people
Palestinians living here in the holyland
and you cannot expect them to go away
they will not go away we will not go
away we are doomed to live here together
and we have to choose whether to share
this land or to share the graveyard
under it exactly and it is inspiring
that despite what that man went through
he's still committed to achieving peace
through talking and it shows that any
conversation around this has to begin
with empathy or we're just
and obviously we don't know how
all this ends but there are a few things
that we do know we know that
dehumanizing people leads to violence we
know that violence leads to even more
brutality and destruction and we know
that crucially breaking that cycle is
unfortunately going to require
leadership significantly different than
the ones currently in
place